welcome to the recruitment roller
coaster podcast my name
is hisham azuz today i'm
joined by ashley lawrence who is the
chief exec
at trinova group which consists of four
distinct brands
and you have trust in soda which
operates in the digital market
you have broadcast search which operates
in the governance market
bio talent that operates in life
sciences
and ex-military careers which is a
social
enterprise now across the group they
have circumnant people
and are based in london manchester
dublin um and also in the states in the
states
uh in the state of uh california ash
thanks for joining me
thanks for having me mate good to uh
finally be here
so i'm sorry i think i've
best intentions i think i've been i'm
due on a few times and uh
you know current pandemic and all that
i've uh i've uh i'm
so here i am so thank you thanks for
having me apologies it's taking me so
long to get here
so so we're doing this remotely
obviously and um
if if there's any sort of tension mental
issues that might you might experience
that but
hopefully this should be absolutely fine
um but
where i was really keen to start ash
and what i really want to focus on today
is is the journey of tranova group
right um and and the four brands that i
just mentioned
um how long have you how about firstly
like how long have you actually been in
the
recruitment industry
give my age away um i started in
recruitment when i was
19 and um you know i'm 34 today
so um so what you know 15 years
okay and you started
searching around you that and you and
you started
at the infamous s3
yeah so just quickly
i just want to ask you one question
around that and we'll segue into
you being um a business owner etc but
like
what what is your opinion of
the s3 culture that you think
made a lot of recruiting entrepreneurs
that made it so great what were the sort
of key ingredients that you saw looking
back
i mean that's a that's a great question
it depends how you quantify culture and
it depends how you
how you know and and also you're making
us an assumption there that it was a
great culture
i think it was a great environment that
that
um you know that drove an
unbelievable amount of competition which
drove the minimum standards and
you know really the lowest common
denominator would probably be
in the top performers in most other
recruitment businesses you know
in the in the in the contracts team that
i worked in when i started at computer
futures
you you'd probably say the top 20
of of that business would you know would
probably be the top one percent across
the industry
if you then built those into any other
businesses just in relation to
to what they may have been billing um so
so the environment was in was was
incredible
you know naturally any environment kind
of stems from from leadership
um i think i i was at computer futures
contracts team in london
you know didn't uh started in 2006. so
you know the the in yeah and the
training was unbelievable
it was exceptional you know you still
have conversations today the people that
have been s3 trains still refer to it
still use it
it's still you know it it still has a
place
in in the present day which just gives
you a sense of just how good that is
a lot of that then is driven by minimum
standards it's driven by
absolute accountability uh visibility
kind of nowhere to hide
there wasn't not a great deal that that
you get in relation to toolkit outside
of training
um really you know your role is
contingency-based
new business you know you'd celebrate
high margins you wouldn't
really be able to be be doing a great
deal of volume with any one client
because you know you'd absolutely not
want to see any margin erosion and your
average margin which
you know would only really be recognized
as good if it was
20 and and above and you know in terms
of having a kind of
unique value proposition you didn't
really have one
um in terms of a tool kit that you could
offer your
client other than your absolute ability
just to just to find people quickly that
again when i said it
wasn't wasn't really one so all you had
was just
you're just surrounded with so many
people that are so
incredibly competent and and you just
and you and you and you just had to
drive competition really you know
everyone
everyone wanted to be um number one
number one really
and the commission structure just it was
not very good you know it's just it's
not a great commission structure so
um really what you you're not looking at
even your earning potential so much
you're just looking to be top of the
leaderboard so
everyone that was brought into the
business was so competitive and it was
always about being top of the
leaderboard you know we
interview people i interviewed people
now
you know 90 of my day is interviewing
people for the various brands and
often you'll you know meet people that
will kind of try and carve out what
they're
what their learning potential looks like
on 150k billings i mean you just
you just wouldn't do that at computer
futures you know you could quite simply
any of your
and any of the numbers that went into
the input to kind of derive what your
earning potential looked like really
started at
10 grand a week weekly gp and nothing
less than that and wasn't really
celebrated you know it's almost like we
haven't earned the right to earn a good
amount
earn a decent amount of commission we'll
pay you well when you when you're when
you're performing at that level so
um i don't you know if in all honesty
it's not a
it's not a culture that we aim to
replicate in any one of our businesses
but in terms of the process the control
the minimum standards the training
then you know that's absolutely that's
absolutely fantastic and there's a lot
you can take from that
i think um just going back to what i
mentioned about the leadership piece
and that is so important for driving the
minimum standards and having
so much accountability in that business
you've got a guy
i know one another was on with you with
me because yeah
i listened to that one but ryan's good
lad
ryan is a great example of of someone
that
you know you just did the reason why i'm
successful
or any anyone else will be successful in
that business
is quite simply hard work and sacrifice
you know you just you just work harder
than anyone
you have to demonstrate a huge amount of
sacrifice
and there was just absolutely no way
that
you would ever use the word luck you
know you never you know say well he got
lucky it was always when
hard work meets opportunity and and and
everything anyone did it was always
quantified it was like well
this person is doing a hex because
they've increased their client calls
they've doubled down on their candidate
calls they're coming in and working on
the weekends you know it was always
hard work meets opportunity rather than
actually so and so got lucky so
there's a i was really lucky when i
started a recruit when i
sat next to a guy called paul knox um
he was uh him and a guy called lawrence
though really were
the two guys that really drove that
business drove them into standards yes
it's interesting so yeah i think this is
what's coming out of it every time i ask
someone around there's free thing
it's it comes back to the standards and
those two names there
i mean i'm in the process of um speaking
to them about coming on the podcast
because a lot of people
have sort of given them credit on on
building that order the culture they
created and
sort of leading the path if you want to
say that and um
so it's interesting that you mentioned
them because they came up from there
well yeah not unbelievable uh manager
i was lucky enough to i sat next to him
for the first 12 months of recruitment
and
you know i i still reference stuff that
he taught me 14 15 years ago you know
that's that's how good he was and i
think a lot of it
a lot of it would would probably you
know sit with
with him as an individual in terms of
how
that culture kind of or the environment
of having an
absolute incredible team um existed but
you know for for someone like noxie yes
absolutely is a massive part of that
but when i did my um when i did my mba
dissertation i was
interviewing lots of like recruitment
entrepreneurs corporate finance people
private equity people to kind of
triangulate a perspective of what really
drives value in a recruitment business
so without wanting to overcomplicate
this and you've got like ebitda and then
multiple that's applied to that
and one of the guys that i interviewed
was russell clements he was the group
ceo of s3
and and you know i was when i was asking
him about what to
value what were the things that s3 did
to really
go and capture the market not just in
the uk but around the rest of the world
and
i was expecting things like you know
leveraging debt first move advantage
into russia
or um uh interbrand synergies or you
know what whatever you might expect to
look like from
from a ceo of a footsie 250 but actually
what his
his his answer is really interesting
because
it's probably what resonates throughout
the entire entirety of s3 certainly
when he would have been there and
certainly when i was there which is
it's about minimum standards it's about
having
these minimum standards that then
compounds
to becoming the competitive advantage
it's not doing any one thing
it's not um it's
it's not being at your desk 831 you know
it's being at your desk and ready to
work by 8 30 and on the phone it's
not being late it's it's going in the
weekends if you need to go in on
weekends and it's just something
it was it was a very it was a small
things you know having a tie on at your
desk being well presented
um it was it was those things that were
really high standards
and that's what kind of compounds if you
think about that many people that many
locations and if you
uphold those minimum standards it's
those things that really
enable you to compete and it was a
little bit like
you know like sparta or 300 where you
know the the
or like the marines you know 99.9 need
not apply it's like
that that was the business and the the
the environment was that no one else can
compete with us and
and actually no no other recruitment
business really exists you know there's
a
and this even then was an incredibly
saturated landscape and it is a very
saturated sector and
but really being s3 you were in a bit of
a bubble you didn't really know anywhere
else existed and
nor were you ever really made reference
to anyone else it was quite simply well
you know you you work for compute
futures and you work for this team and
by virtue of that you're you know you're
in the top one percent of the industry
and
and this is what we expect from you so
it's a bit it's a bit of a
long-winded answer to probably what
should have been a really
straightforward question i know that's
i think that you you're the first person
you've spoken about that s free
environment in a different way
and i think that that's really
interesting but that that's really
interesting and around the
yeah when you're speaking to russell
clements around what makes recruitment
business
more valuable or builds the equity value
and actually it was about yeah the
the the compound of minimum standards
that's really interesting so
okay
sorry there's just on that point there's
a really good book called earn the right
to win
it's a i actually think it's meant to be
a business book but it's about
minimum standards and it was about i
think it's an nfl coach
and it was all the things that he used
to make sure the players got right so
similar things like
be it training on time make sure you get
enough sleep make sure your nutrition is
right you know make sure that
you're basically you're 110 percent of
the version of what you can be and
he did this really interesting book
around the load of stuff that
that that they would do and it's just
it's just the small things like
you know business business cards right
you know you you celebrate when you when
you
run out of a box of business cards
because you don't you know you've done
your job
you're out there you're in front of
people that should be celebrated just
lots of little things like that
it's uh very similar in terms of what
that book
what is in that book and actually what
what what s3 did as
a bit or i say s3 when i was i think
there was nine bands i'm really only
referring to
to computer futures which was you know
probably
you know a little bit biased but was
probably the number one fan
here we go that's that's that's that's
that's that mentality isn't it
yeah okay so okay so
let's just let's just give context with
people and break this down love no i
really enjoyed you talking about s3 and
that i think that's really interesting
so so in 2009 you started the business
with strategic move
uh started a business called strategic
move which ultimately was
a ret to wreck right so you did that
from
what i can see um correct me if i'm
wrong did that for
near six years yeah correct yeah did
that for six years
and then in 2013
you started the first brand within the
tranova group which you trust in soda
correct a year later broadgate search
correct and then for the last two and a
half years you've also
added bio talent and then
and then and then throughout his
ex-military career has been part of it
so so um so buyer talent was january
2018
so um soda was incorporated in august
2013 broad gate january 2015 buy a
talent january 2018
roll up to trinovo group really was
january 2019
and ex-military careers as a social
enterprise was really founded before all
of that that was uh
that was a an initiative that me and my
brother launched to
help excuse me help veterans um
find employment uh or help with the kind
of
transition in that move from kind of the
military into sydney street and
you know recognize the the uh need for
training and demystification
and and actually um you know present day
x military careers is
as a social enterprises we advertise
about 7 000 vacancies from
about 350 different clients across the
uk and predominantly the us and as i say
that
that's the social enterprise that kind
of operates that net neutral and as a
non-for profit but
okay um yeah that that was really
founded by my brother and i in 2013 and
it's just growing organically and
exponentially year one year
okay cool so so we're going to attempt
to sort of break down
the sort of key moments the learnings
mistakes right so i think what's
interesting about
your journey and what i know so far ash
is that trusting soda was a joint
venture
with someone that had a plan um and was
something
someone that you was getting involved
with to to back but also obviously offer
expertise and be involved
right and then broadcast search
obviously
you started that with ben adams who's
again someone that you started with
someone else
um and then in terms of the buy talent
again
it was you getting involved with other
people that were going to really focus
and drive that
yeah correct yeah so yeah
so so i think i just find that so
interesting right so
i think um firstly for me
what i'd love you to sort of just speak
about i guess the real benefit of a
hindsight here that
um talking about the start of this
journey with these brands and what you
know now
but i guess the first thing is like how
much did it help
having that black book of recruiters
when you started this business
like how much did that help at the
beginning in terms of knowing exactly
who you wanted to get involved in those
things
i mean absolutely you know it
quite simply absolutely helps um you
know we were
when we had launched soda i think was
you know at the kind of time where where
being on site or the msp and rpo
proposition was
was becoming more of a kind of bau
solution to
equipment as we know it and kind of move
away from
agencies being able to deliver on a
contingency-based business
basis and high margins and low volume
approach was
just just just ceasing to exist so
from a timing perspective it helps
because i you know i knew a lot of
recruiters that actually were deciding
to go on site and actually then they
were
they were great contacts when we when we
launched sodor and
in um in and in building out a kind of
client portfolio but
the it's also helpful naturally
as we you know scaling um uh
trust in soda you know there wasn't
there wasn't it was dave and i that set
up soda and there wasn't a
dave dave wasn't coming with a team of
six or eight people that
that he wanted to be financed really it
was him and i with a joint venture and
i was able really to to lean on my
network and
i think i brought in the first six or
eight hires um
through my network in sodor and you know
a handful of those highlights
are still with the business and director
roles haley's out in the us
and um sam's associate director for our
palm team for example
so you know those guys are still with us
and have been with us really since
inception so
so to not to not to underplay it it's
it it was great you know it's superb the
um
uh that that that being said because
because we wanted to have that agility
you know we were mindful of my network
really and
and um and not wanting to be
too regimented in our structure and that
we
would
really be relying on a handful of good
recruiters coming in to help us shape
the proposition
the short for that really is not having
from from day one
a really robust vision and plan and and
that's sort of the opportunity cost is
is arguably
you know are you better off not to have
a networking recruitment whatsoever and
you've got a really strong plan and the
vision and and start there
and don't deviate from that is is you
know it's
one approach counter to the you know
just be more fluid be a bit more agile
or shape the
businesses you identify to talent that
was our approach but
is that is that something that would you
is that something that you'd
check like do you think you if you were
to start again because because i
i've heard you say before that when you
start recruiting bits you should you
should try and
start with the end in mind so in terms
of the vision value proposition
do you think that's something that you'd
actually iron out and focus i think
that's typically something that people
won't spend time on or think about is
get money in the bank
and it's it's get those things rather
than the importance of the division do
you think that's something that you
change
um mate 100 i
having a plan is just is business
critical uh
for for me anyway in in in setting out
you know having a plan
as as quick not as critical as cash flow
though right you know so
you you you need cash otherwise your the
plan is a little bit redundant
but um so that so there is that piece
where
you you have to make placements you
haven't got the luxury of not making
placements and
really in in in the early years you
haven't really got the luxury of turning
things down you know
despite wanting to stick to a plan and
um
and the value proposition really you're
you haven't got the luxury of turning
things down and cash flow is king
but it shouldn't detract from having a
plan and a vision because
because that helps with engagement and
it helps when you're selling the
business not just for people to come and
join you but actually when you're
speaking
to clients really and you're shaping you
know what makes you unique how do you
differentiate ultimately what's in it
for them
and that story is so so important and so
powerful on how you communicate that
story is really important and
um and maybe that we we weren't great at
that
in in you know in the in the first or
second year of solar
you know fast forward to trinovo group
present day
our mission our purpose our values it
just absolutely drives the business but
it's a different business it's
you know close to 19 head count in three
bands and and four locations and
29 million pound turnover so you're
afforded
you haven't got the luxury of of not
having a plan and and
having a purpose for employee engagement
but equally it's a very different
business to
when you set up from day one which is
just got a bit of cash
in the bank you know but having a plan
definitely helps with that so you know
that's
that's definitely one thing that i
didn't do was was to have a plan i
probably if i was gonna if i was gonna
do anything tomorrow
you know you'd have a really robust plan
um so just to help me out then
so ash lawrence when you started
soda with dave and then sort of i guess
fast forward a year another business
involved and these things but like what
does a typical day look like for you
like what
what i'm sure it's changed but overall
what have been your core
responsibilities as the executive of
this growing business that you've you've
grown quickly
sorry what what is there what's day to
day
no no for you as ashley lawrence the
chief exec of the these businesses these
brands
like what of what have you ended up
focusing on you said at the beginning of
this that nine percent of your time now
spend
looking obviously you're speaking to
people potentially working for the group
but like what have been your core
responsibilities because you wasn't
someone that
got in the tools hadn't recruited in
digital since she was an s3
so like for you what have been your
focuses
or what have been your responsibilities
with within this journey of the last
um few years just to help me out on that
yeah that might that's what i mean i'm
still very very client-facing you know
uh still since inception until present
day is still very you know
i bring in lots of lots of clients and
we'll nurture relationships and
there's no getting away from that but uh
for me i
i still do deals now you know i uh did
the deal last week a big statement of
work that um
uh turnover group level a big csr
project so
um that was nice to put that deal on the
board last last week so actually after
that i actually um
so that was one that was like how why
why was that
why is that a big moment because that
was one of the the questions that ben
wanted me to speak to about around
winning that csr project
like
why is that important to you guys
because he he believed that that sort of
really embodies the vision for your
your business and the group how many how
many questions have you got how many
persons have
um it's a groundbreaking project
um it's it's its focus is
is really um it really brings together
a number of of our businesses parts its
focuses
is basically our mission is to turn over
a group is to build diverse teams that
represent the world we live in and
the project in itself is is basically
driven behind having unconscious bias in
the
in the sourcing and screening process
and then delivering a
diverse candidate pool that you know is
difficult to reach and and
from a social impact perspective what
the project is
it it doesn't get announced for a week
until week to day but from the first
social impact
perspective it's a fantastic initiative
which
um aims to find a thousand uh
graduates and apprenticeships that have
been displaced due to coving and it
brings together
ten of the world's leading brands as for
this initiative
and appointed as the um
as the uh exclusive resourcing partner
that will
work that will filter this the screening
process and the reason why i said
that why that you know firstly i think
it's a fantastic
fantastic thing to do you know in in
terms of having
being involved with the project of that
time but but it brings together
a number of parts for us so you know
we've got dna framework
we won apsco uh dni award for excellence
last year the year before with finalists
for csr
um and we were able to really bring that
together in a more of a distinct sort of
narrative and a bit of a story around
how our businesses as weeks maturity and
our focus being that we're able to
provide our clients with
sort of meaningful data um and insights
that
enables them to build diverse teams and
it was a lot of work that went into it
and um and i see that as
i wouldn't say it's first mover
advantage because i think other
recruitment businesses were able to do
that but
that will become more bau as as yeah i
think that
that's that's a question that's coming
up for me actually if i'm listening to
it like first i think that's amazing
i think i love the mission i think it's
great and and i love that
so i guess commercially if i'm listening
to this right now
like how just just quickly on this i
know it's not just about this right it's
about the vision the purpose but how is
that
how was that mission how was you guys
talking about these things these are
things you want to impact these are
things that
you're really motivated about making a
difference for these businesses you work
with how is that giving you a commercial
advantage over other businesses that
might have been bid into that statement
of work
like how does that help if i'm this
right now should i be thinking about
that
is it just it sounds nice but like how
has that actually helped how have you
found it's helped you over the last
few years more recently this project how
has it helped you have a
competitive advantage um
quite simply it's it's in it's in hiring
and culture
because if you want to if we're
investors and people goals
and we want to reach investors and
people platinum this year there's a
great deal that goes into that but
simply for me stems from
having value-based hiring assessments
you know so our values being passion
collaboration and innovation
and if what you do is is is your
interview assessments look like values
based assessments and
and actually how you renumerate reward
promote and recognize
um consultants based on values and not
just
revenue you know that that's why when
you asked me earlier about
s3 or computer futures and it being a
great culture it was not great culture
it's a good environment
for high performers a good culture for
me is
about employee engagement and people
enjoying coming to work and
being able to have the freedom to
innovate you know you wouldn't get the
freedom to innovate at
computer future's really you're fairly
binary your square square peg square
hole
because was part of the machine there's
no real freedom to innovate but to
innovate you have to have a
a culture that celebrates failure and
iterations of that failure look like
innovation
so so to answer the question the
why that's great for us to to to win has
been uh
it's actually the people part of it it's
it stems from us
really reshaping what was important in
our business and it wasn't necessarily
buildings you know we reshaped it and we
we had it focused on on values and then
that that gives you
great people in the business it improves
your um
[Music]
previous churn rate and we've got a you
know this kind of
organic or meritocratic growth as part
of your culture is super important as
well
um but it all stems from from values and
having the right values and living by
those values and
and really employing engagement and
innovation billings for me are a
byproduct of
of having a fantastic culture so
ash do you do you think a recruitment
business that isn't is nowhere near your
size 10 people eight people 12 people do
you think they have a culture and should
put an importance or priority on values
if if if i was gonna
start again tomorrow having a plan
uh you know number one but having uh
having a having values absolutely is
is critical having a mission
having a purpose is just so important
it's just so important for
employee engagement but equally it
becomes part of your narrative and what
differentiates you to your clients as
well
you know we we didn't get that right
from inception
and i work with a guy called mike smith
he's
uh he was on the board of s3 actually he
was a
md yeah yeah i know actually so
mike was with us for for a couple of
years and he's brilliant
and when i sat down with mike for the
first time because i was looking to
bring in a non-exec
the first thing he said to me was what
is your mission and what are your values
and it's it's almost embarrassing
timeline of business just quickly on
just for context
yeah that would have been probably the
end of 2015.
yeah there's a really good book called
traction by the way
that i recommend for anyone if they're
gonna you know if you're thinking about
setting up your own businesses
start from chapter one in traction and
follow it follow that path
as a book it's sort of kind of built for
businesses that are
probably 40 people looking to get to 80.
and there's some shortfalls in there
but um but it's still suitable for
people that want to start from himself
from day one because it's about vision
and purpose and engagement and and
actually sales become a bit of a
byproduct so
so so that book is great but but i was
lucky in working with mike mike was
almost a real
you know a real life example of of
talking me
through that process and so yeah he was
he was very good but
uh to answer the question absolutely
value should should be day one
okay so just one more thing that i
wanted to
ask you around and sort of early days
knowing what you know now we always talk
about in this podcast
around hiring is one of the biggest
challenges getting the right people
but what see so the things that you're
talking about now ash a common theme
that i'm finding is
sort of if you're a recruitment business
owner and you do want to grow you're
doing a scale you have to have the
mentality and do things that
um you should be doing at a certain
stage before you're doing it
so it's the things you're talking about
have values have a vision in these
things but typically what seems to
happen
with businesses that don't scale is that
they'll they'll say to themselves i'll
do that when we get 15 heads or i'll do
that i'll i'll think about values when i
get to
the 20 milestone or whatever so what i
wanted to ask you was
because what keeps coming up again is
around the processes around
um getting people to do things that
means that ash is then spending time on
other things
like for your operations team
and the the non-billing part of the
business
who would be your first free hires
if you would if you would if you were to
do that did you hear that
i just literally just sorry about the
internet literally just broke out for a
second
i think it's what you said what would be
your first three operations
yeah okay that's good guess there
um and what what would the size of the
team
team be so let's say that i'm listening
to this i'm like right you know what
i i've been i've just been coasting i'm
serious about growing my business
like and it's time and time again it
seems like
you have to do make these decisions as
if you're already there
right that you're at the point that you
want to get to sort of thing that that's
what keeps coming up
with the the business owners that i
speak to the
50-plus heads or whatever so and and
having operations having the right tools
always seems to be
the all people go i wish i got a
operations manager before i did i wish i
got
this person before i did so i guess it
could be tools it could be people but
what would be like the three things that
you'd invest in that would be perceived
as non-billing that you think
really give you the best chance of
scaling with the right foundations
okay um first and foremost finance and
accounting
right you know you you you need to know
what cash you've got
uh you need to know meaningfully what
you're you know what your
your nfi is what you want it to be what
your trigger is to hire is what your
cost of sales are
super important you know that cash flow
piece is is critical to growth so
having someone in the finance and
accounting role actually isn't it isn't
an expensive hiring it doesn't need to
be
doesn't need to be a full-time hire you
know we we outsourced our accounting
function
until we were about 30 40 people it was
outsourced
um and and getting that getting a real
sense of
of your numbers uh for me is absolutely
critical if
we can include that into an operation
yeah and operations higher
um i would then say
kind of depends if you're you know if
you're doing contract or contract
or perm but again it doesn't need to be
a full-time hire
but someone in a training and
development role um
you know we've got we've got um
that that's you know that that in all
honesty is a high that we should have
made well ahead of
of when we actually did and we still
don't have someone in a full-time l d
role we use um we use jeremy for our
academies we use ashley rice for our
future leaders program and again you
know he's kind of
sort of based on demand we can we can
use them jeremy we work with more of a
on a quarterly basis now based on our
kind of
academy and hiring needs and and
actually helped us for that
organic marital classic growth piece of
people that want to become future
leaders and run teams so
having someone in a training and
development role it does give you scale
it gives you the opportunity to scale
because
if your business is basically saying
well we're 10 people now
we want to get to 30 but i'll tell you
what i can't get there because i
just can't find 20 half a million pound
billers
it you know that that's then then it's
your fault as a business owner to ever
expect there to be 20
half a million pound billers ever
actively looking at the market
and they've and ever looking to to join
your business you know so
to be proactive in that to have an
academy that enables you to
have some certainty on head count and
growth
you need a training and development
piece s3 was so successful
because it had the most unbelievable
training infrastructure and it had this
kind of constant stream of people you
know
by that size you just like to turn into
growth trajectory and head count
and you know you get rid of the people
that can't quite make it and continue to
invest into training so
yeah you know we we're not big on the
churn piece but we've invested heavily
into training and actually as i say
as a business even as 10 people that
should be in operations higher but it
doesn't need to be a full-time hire you
know you can bring people in on a
quarterly basis or as and when you want
to see something
so accountancy finance learning
development
what would be the final one
so i'm i'm i'm a little bit torn in this
because
i want i want to say marketing but then
but personally and we and we have a
great marketing goal
in our business but i think that would
be misleading people in that
marketing is is an operations role
because
i think sales and marketing are the same
thing and actually you get consultants
doing
the right things when they should be
doing them and doing them correctly
actually your marketing is into the
fabric of your business and your sales
consultants recognize the value of
just basically being amazing marketeers
that's so i i i wouldn't want to mislead
people by saying well hire a marketing
person you'd be great at marketing
because actually the opposite is
probably true
you need a better integrated solution so
if i wasn't if i wasn't going to pick
marketing which would be the obvious one
you
you'd probably say an operations person
or operations manager that can
basically just let the sales people sell
you know let them just
just do their job there's so much as a
smaller business probably more so it's a
smaller business maybe there is when
you're
when you're a larger business you have
economies of scale you know as a smaller
business you can just get
you can just get swamped with um the
stuff you know on the phone to
to job board yeah all sorts yeah yeah
definitely yeah i think that that's one
of the
okay that's really interesting so what i
wanted to
um also get your thoughts on ash so so
i've heard you say that
i think this might have been in line or
the right sort of timeline with um
mike smith getting involved as well
which i'd be keen to because
a lot of business owners i feel want any
of these i've had that conversation with
loads of people but
a lot of people sat down with people
that they're like nah don't rate them at
all whatever and
so i'm not sure it makes a good enemy
right but i heard you say
before ash around that you got to around
the 25 heads mark broadgate was
at this point soda was existed then um
and you finally got around to actually
finding out what the traits were the
personality traits were of the people in
your business
and you had no one that were completely
finishers
yeah yeah that's true yeah so yeah
yes so i think that's really interesting
right so i think for me there's a bit
there's a bit in there around
how do you think that's held you back at
that beginning stage because it seems
like you had to go through that
those first two years and then you made
changes but how do you think that that
sort of potentially held the business
back
and also psychometric testing finding
out how your people function how
important is that is doing that sooner
rather than later
um so i guess so i i'll answer them in
the order
mate but but i like it just just quickly
on ned's
uh non-accept directors and and having
someone that's been there that's done it
really what you're what you're what
you're paying for for whatever in other
words is
is where their fails whether where
they've got it wrong that's the great
advice it's like
i've done it i lost a fortune doing it
and i certainly wouldn't be doing this
again and hope you know that that's
really what you're buying so
to have an nd that's you know as bit of
a is tried and tested and as
as the stripes is is super important and
and actually i could sympathize with
that most people have found varying
degrees of success because
um because i found the same you know uh
there's a lot of a lot of guys out there
and girls that are doing non-exec roles
and
and i think if you get the right one
it's it's imperative i mean arguably you
could put that in there with those
operations higher yeah
one day a month with a non-executive
it's fairly critical
the next part being the behavioral
assessment that was a bell bin
behavioral assessment that i rolled out
when i was doing the
organizational behaviour module of my
mba and i found it super interesting it
was a
you know people's perception of
themselves isn't necessarily
the reflection the the perspective that
other people have from them so you sort
of
buy this 360 assessment and it's really
almost enlightening for the recipient
that realizes
you know actually i'm not the creative
director that i think i am
i'm a bit of a wally and you know i'm
actually better off at this
and and um and then when you look at
that in balance on
in a team you know you have strengths
and weaknesses so
your strengths just place your strengths
you know your weaknesses just become
allowable
if you're in the balanced team and
that's why
you know the difference in culture when
you think about s3 to our business
s3 business had the same kpis for
everyone everyone had the
same you know amount of calls for
candidates clients tvs and interviews
offers you know
it was all the same for every individual
and it completely overlooks that what's
important about culture is plan to
people's strengths
engagement and them enjoying their job
so we use cube19
as a our dials and kpi metrics that
actually you can shape the kpis based on
someone's strengths
and if you're fantastic in this one area
then we can you know we
can shape your performance indicators to
have you working in that area and you
enjoy it and you're engaged and it
provided you with a team that
gives you balance and a bit more like
complete finishes and that and actually
that works pretty well and
that's what that behavioral assessment
taught me when i when i did it
um you know do we use them in
psychometric testing in the interview
process um
currently no we don't um
it is definitely something that we're
that we're looking into
um i think that this can be
i think it can be difficult difficult
but for me personally
you know i think it can be difficult to
to judge someone based on a
and the score that they've done and you
don't know what the environment looks
like you don't know how long it's taking
them you don't know what frame of mind
they were in at the time of taking it
you don't know you know it's it's a
there's a lot that goes into a test
itself that might have
um they might have influences that
you're not aware of
personally i've always i've always
interviewed
this is this this is not a
recommendation by the way but i've
always interviewed without rcb you know
i've just walked into the room
and got a sense of someone almost
immediately with with um
what type of character they were and how
they conducted themselves how they spoke
you know was always more important to me
than what was on the cv so
um i think our business is having to
grow up a little bit in that sense and
you know within
multiple locations and the head count
growth we want to see we
we do need to have maybe a little bit
more certainty or certainly provides
team leaders managers and directors with
with more of a toolkit into making the
correct assessment
so psychometric access and probably
features there but i've never you know
it
i've never let a psychometric test hold
me back from that
okay so just on on this point ash
what i'd be really keen to just get your
thoughts on is more about
you personally really so again what i
keep learning from
recruitment business owners that
successfully scaled their businesses is
that they've had to get really good at
empowering their people
right and what that means is is that you
have to get better and more comfortable
and allowing people to do things that i
don't know early on you might have
thought that you could have done better
or
these types of things right and that
might be you personally or it might be
the leaders
underneath you but i guess
for ashley lawrence in this business
this growing this becomes
a real big vehicle now loads of people
involved i think one of the things that
a lot of small business owners struggle
with is
is the letting go is the letting go of
certain things right
and you've also kept involved with
certain parts but like
how have you made sure personally as the
chief exec
of this business has evolved have you
always ensured that
you've got a purpose and you haven't
lost that you know
yeah so uh yeah it's interesting because
like you know succession power planning
um
efficient delegation empowerment are all
are all big parts of being a good leader
but
is is the question more you know if you
do that too often then you haven't got a
job
i think because that's what can hold
people back and doing it
okay i mean how have you sort of how did
this sort of yeah how have you dealt
with that
um if if you were if it depends what
type of business
you you want to build right if your
business is predominantly driven by
your own ego and it's a bit of a
lifestyle choice then you might really
struggle with that
if you want to build a big business and
multitude of locations and really drive
value you have to get out of the way
right because you have to hire people
that are better than you it's just
and that's easy for me to do you know
people out there
so you wouldn't you know you you know we
had a fantastic
chief operations officer and it would be
silly for me
to hire someone at that level and just
be in the way all the time you know you
you've got to make good hides you've got
you you comes up all the time and it's i
actually hate hearing it but
you don't want to be the mo you know the
most most intelligent or the clever the
smartest yeah
you know that that's fairly true so to
get growth
you need empowerment get growth you need
to hire good people around you and
good people want headroom to grow and
progression and
and um succession planning and it is
part of scaling a business
so really you have to get out of the way
so for for me
i'd do the job until i stopped enjoying
it you know it's it's like
and and if there's someone better better
than me to do the job and i'm you know
i'm sure
i'm sure there will be but while i'm as
passionate as i am and
you know and absolutely committed to
to the job and and you know driving the
right behaviors through the organization
and setting the right minimum standards
and continuing
for me to you know what i feel are the
you know the number one privately owned
business in in in our spaces then
you know why while we are that business
then
and i think i've got a job but i think
that not sure you basically want to
to yeah to get scale you need you need
to get other people to
to do those roles and then get out the
way and give them room for progression
and at some point you know when when the
business wants to go from
150 to 400 heads maybe i'm not the right
person for
for that role because but there but i
would have to recognize that and
and either empower someone internally or
bring someone in externally
that is able to do that job but you know
for me it's always what's in the best
interest
the business is not about you know my
ego i i want to be the ceo of
of the group forever so as long as i
feel i'm capable and competent and i'm
passionate and
um you know if we identify someone
that's more more confident capable and
passionate at them
than that's in the best interest of
everyone in the business and and for me
as well because when you set up a
business you're an equity holder it's
like only in the house
you need to you want to see that export
value grow
and sometimes that that means that you
you don't live in it day to day so
it's um we'll we'll
we'll see but but you know currently i'm
i'm enjoying it and there's plenty to do
i think i mentioned earlier the large
part of my job is
is interviewing you know is is ensuring
that we've got
putting the right people in the right
roles and providing head room and
password progression
for people that are competent and
capable and
and you know organizationally ensuring
that we've got that continued growth
trajectory
and internationalization and improving
our operational efficiencies and
creating the right infrastructure that's
going to enable us to continue to scale
that's you know that's it takes a bit
yeah so this this
leads me quite nicely into we've got
about 15 minutes haven't we right
is that yeah cool yeah so this just
leads me quite nicely into what i wanted
to ask you because what what
what has been key parts of enabling you
to scale is
getting involved with people that
ultimately
can help you do that right in terms of
the different brands and these things so
you're talking you were talking about
some of the traits there what you're
talking about is having some the real
humility to
sort of pre um understand that there
will be people better than you in these
things your ego is not
in the way but so the the likes of dave
ben
the other the other people or the other
person that you got involved with for
bio talent
what were they doing james what what
were the what were the common traits you
saw in them
the the that left you feeling really
confident to
to help them or be part of their journey
what were the common traits you think
that
the recipe for for them to have the a
good chance that going well
um interestingly mate i
i don't think there were common themes
um and i think that's what makes
you know if you can if you can get
balance right if you can you know you
don't want everyone having the
same traits or demonstrate the same
behaviors or have the same strengths
to build a team um you know
you need you need people's um skills to
to complement one another so like in in
dave why is
incredibly creative is his big focus on
branding and marketing
ben from uh you know you know it's
incredibly commercial fantastic you know
in front of clients probably one of the
hardest workers i've ever worked with
james is a fantastic salesperson but
brilliant when it comes to like you know
systems operations and control
um dj he's missing from that list but we
hired last year as our
chief operations officer brings that
together then from
really from a robust operations finance
and accounting perspective so
when you're on a board when you're in a
board meeting you've got
an incredible balance and skill set and
and different individuals that bring
different things to the table
and that i think is really important and
and you know if any everyone's looking
to set up tomorrow
um and you're and you're thinking who
should i do it with
probably wouldn't necessarily think
about who's your best mate
at that time you know you're more
thinking about who do i admire and
and who what can they teach me that i
don't already know and
how could they complement my skill set
you know that that would probably be the
individual
um you'd want to look to in setting up
on your own because complementary skill
sets are so important
yeah okay interesting i think that's
what makes this industry so exciting
right
right that how you've done things and
who you are and the characteristics
make you does like i know i could be the
opposite but still have
as much or more success right there
isn't a real clear cut of what you need
to be
i think i find that super interesting
um yeah and were you gonna say something
i just gotta say i mean i don't think i
don't think any anyone's found the
secret recipe of
of um you know this is this this is what
the
this is what a half a million pound
biller looks like as a trainee you know
no no one's got any certainty on that
and you can try and refine it and put
science towards it just
a lot of it is environment a lot of it's
stuff that you just can't teach a lot of
it is willingness and desire and
and the ability to to just work work
hard you know it's difficult to instill
that and it usually for me stems from
stems from um you know right right
down to childhood really so so there's
there's so much that goes into
understanding the behaviors of someone
and and why they might be successful and
i certainly haven't worked out what what
that is but
i you know but if i think about our
business
business group as a business and i think
about
ss just sorry to keep on going back to
to using s3's
or computer futures but you know we we
we have got
more creative consultants than than the
business that i was at when i started
computer futures you know i've got to
give a shout out to oliver
um perry and also to kevin adam who were
both in our ballgate and soda in in
ireland and
you know how they innovate and how they
do things differently and
how they encourage other people and
drive engagement you know they're
two of the better examples across the
industry for me i never think about
billing consultants you know we've got
we've got
people in our own business now that that
bought a bill more and
on contracts than people i'd work with
computer futures so
it's um but if you if you look at the
themes in those individuals you know
the business has to buy the
infrastructure it has to it has to
provide
a great deal of time there's a maturity
curve that goes with
someone understanding your organization
and being able to do things differently
and being encouraged
to try and innovate so it's not a
one-size-fits-all approach
but i think if you're an organization
that can give people
freedom a little bit headroom with the
right infrastructure around training and
development you
you're doing as much as you possibly can
to get a consultant to succeed in your
business
okay so as we come as you come to the
end here ashley i've got what i want to
ask you one more question then i want to
i just want to get your thoughts on sort
of
how you've approached the last couple of
months so
this question actually um um lauren and
carl's
lauren tren encouraged me to ask you
this so
i think on on the face of it right i'm
sure you know this but
there's a lot of recruiting agencies in
the uk the number always changes but
circle around for
30 000 let's say eight of those are sub
10 staff
so on the face of it a lot of people
will look at you and your business and
think it's just completely
out of reach never going to be that or
these things in terms of the size
profitability or whatever but
obviously if you think about over the
last few years
or just the whole journey so far what do
you think of have been the sort of
biggest factors
to the success so far do you think
um um if you asked that question lauren
trent
yeah gotta give her a shout out
yeah i recently recently met a
shareholder last friday actually
we rolled out our emi scheme and and
then we had just under 20 people become
shareholders of the group and and and
that's a
that's an ingredient for success in
itself you have to you know
we how uh how have we been able to get
that scale
especially you need to be in sectors
that can scale um
you need to you need to have the right
infrastructure you need to have the
right people in the right roles
the right financial and performance
metrics in place
[Music]
collaboration is super important
you know encouraging your consultants to
share information and not
um you know not not work as individuals
i think um i think the higher end piece
it stems from though
you know in in getting that right
getting the right people in the right
roles
and then equally providing a path of
progression but you know not saying well
you've
lucky you you've got a job here's a
phone in the computer come back to me
when you built half a million pounds you
know it's a bit more like
these are the stepping stones that we
that we'll lay out to help you get there
and it's the business's responsibility
to do that i think i think often that
that narrative needs to change a little
bit i think
like some businesses there's a level of
expectancy that you give someone the job
on the phone and
and they owe you something and and
actually they don't as a
as a business you you should recognize
your responsibility
to to invest in into so many different
areas and i think that's
i think is us recognizing that in terms
of you know a great operations function
a great shared service and
our business is really scaled when we
got there you know we've got um
hr manager and compliance manager and
chief operations officer finance
accounting manager
marketing manager director of internal
recruitment you know
these are these effectively to a lot of
businesses look like quite high cost of
sales and they're not prepared to invest
into it and
actually i share that perspective i was
very similar to that in my first couple
of years i just thought it seemed like a
quite a
quite high cost and and actually it's
that operational piece
is so important having having that
infrastructure as a support function
that's going to enable you to scale
um i think i think i think you know in
the in the last few years we've invested
heavily in those areas and
and quite simply recruitment we
shouldn't over complicate it's
it's just getting the getting the right
people you know and and get them in the
right roles and
provide the right retention tools let
people earn well
give them a path of progression that
might look like building manager or pnl
responsibility and then a continued path
beyond that and
um to get up to to to build a big
business you have to
basically be prepared to give give some
of it away you know give it to the
people that are working really hard day
to day
and enable them to to benefit from the
businesses success
um yeah love that so before
we finish ash i wanted to just get your
thoughts on what what your sort of
mindset has been over the the sort of
covid period
i'm sure like what what were your sort
of head count growth goals before
covered
um uh what the heck i've got growth
goals
i mean we've increased our head count
during co-op that's what i mean so i
just
yeah why i ask you that is because i
think and obviously just because of
me new ham chats and stuff i feel like a
lot of people going into covid
potentially just going completing the
defensive just because
it was they looked at their cash flow
not in a good spot or whatever
and then there'll be some people like
you i feel like that tries to recognize
opportunities and
haven't dropped your targets or whatever
so i was just keen to get a bit of
perspective of what your goals were
before and if they've stayed the same
and how have you gone about
still trying to achieve the growth and
the opportunity and the the things that
you wanted to
before all this [ __ ] went down basically
yeah i mean
i mean mate firstly what you know how
how tough is that right
q2 unprecedented there's not a
there's not a rule book that exists
there's no past it's been trodden in the
past so
in the past story so you know you're
trying to instill confidence and
and i think in that you you have to show
a great deal of
authenticity um and empathy and
and as a leadership team we were
brilliant right you know just
were able to move quickly and adjust and
innovate and rethink our pricing we
point resources into areas and
of demand and we you know we did that
quickly and as as you mentioned you know
the right financial
and performance metrics in place are
critical to
being able to not only just compete in
q2 but to sustain growth in q2
it's really important as well we were 94
of target for our q2
and that was that q2 target we set
ourselves last year
we didn't move it we kept that in place
so we performed well in that quarter
um um
[Music]
but you know it's it's there's a lot
there's a number of things that we're
able to do in
in court too it doesn't look like growth
you know that we're able to
we're able to improve a lot of the
infrastructure we had in the business we
hired kara from faden as a director of
talent that would help us on the
resource plans we
built out our organizational structures
um not just
this year for next year for for growth
and
and actually the leadership team were
incredible and and the individuals we
had in the business really did apply to
themselves so um
i that you know i think i think we
thought as an opportunity to grow
actually we
were in a good good position
and we felt you know recruitment is a
saturated market and as the market
contracts
there's still opportunity for market
share um because it's such
a saturated market so our competitors
are over overly utilizing furlough
you know we could there's an opportunity
for us to maybe speak to clients that we
wouldn't have done otherwise and
and um and we you know we applied
ourselves and we continued to
to compete and we felt that you treat
people
the right way correctly and
come out of it the other side is
stronger than ever so yeah um
yeah you know i'm not i'm not gonna like
glorify the period it's difficult
it's been difficult yeah i think what
one came to us
for let you go is um you spoke you're
clearly
the sort of journal that you've been on
you've recognized and been on the
journey of the importance of values
vision
people culture these things spoken a lot
about that and i think from the
conversations
i'm having i don't know what your
perspective is but from the
conversations that
i've been having it seems like this
period has enabled
um employees to look at
in the mirror which is the business they
work for and look at their culture
and if it's a business they support
business that they like a business that
they're proud to be a part of during
this period
or it's left people disappointed they're
going you know what i've hated how ash
has dealt with this or
whatever right so i guess the question
is really is like how much do you think
that investment in your culture
has helped you achieve those things and
have helped you during the last three
four months
critical a hundred percent critical
it's it's very difficult to um you know
very difficult indeed to
to keep a business together right when
everyone's kind of working from
from home it's really difficult but
culture and accountability and
engagement and having a great leadership
team
is is critical to that so so yeah
without absolutely without
without our culture we wouldn't we
wouldn't probably you know
but it's very difficult i think i think
to continue to
to compete in q2 and and hire talent is
is it is another thing i think you know
that's just us demonstrating our
continued investment back into the
business and
you know we'll we'll we'll come out this
come out the other side stronger than
ever i think i think
just i guess pick up on on that point
i think it's easy it's easy to
to do well in a in a good market you
know it's it's a little bit like
you know we've grown from you know not
to not to 90 people in a relatively
short period of time over seven year
period and
you know have one award so best agency
with one of the bands every single
awards you know you know
um dudes out out there or the ones that
were attending anyway and
you're a little bit like imposter
imposter syndrome you know a little bit
like you know this is this is easy we
we we're in awards we're hiring great
people and our business is growing
and you sort of think that it's come
around a little bit too easy and
actually
the kovid period was a great test of
that it was
it was a you know that impostor syndrome
is definitely gone
um and and yeah it's it was a bit of a
reality check and and we you know as i
said we've really evaluated the business
got the right
financial performance metrics in place
and and we're in a really good place for
for growth and internationalization for
the rest of this year but
it was a tough period and and um you
know let's let's see whether or not it
returns again but certainly we've
started to see some confidence in the
market come back
already love that
final question really how how do you see
how do you see the the land lay over the
next six to 12 months what do you think
will be the
the biggest shift do you think in the
recruitment industry
um in the in the uk recruitment industry
whatever just whatever comes to mind
what do you think what do you think all
stay or how do you think the land will
lay as we all start to come
back out and dance i think
i think it's a really difficult question
uh i thought i was done about five
minutes
sorry um
you know i think i think so i think
certainly
you know we're mindful of mindful of
ir35 mindful of brexit in the uk
so you know a lot of businesses now if
they're not they should be looking to
internationalize um making him you know
we got our office and it was a big
investment for us in in in the us and
we've
we've also got a kind of a big strategic
focus for us towards towards dax is
switzerland and germany i think we'll
certainly see more
uk businesses looking to diversify
outside of the uk and internationalize i
think it's absolutely certain that
that will happen i think
i think recruiters quite rightly will it
will expect flexibility and working
conditions
you know i i was a little bit surprised
to see so many businesses go back to the
office
and wearing it with a badge of honor
that they were back in the office
i don't know for me i just felt that you
sort of missing the point a little bit
and overlooking the
the safety piece and you know we're
we're not returning to the office we'll
review it
on on the first of september but you
know we sort of came out and said we
won't be returning and i think quite
rightly um
people aren't overly comfortable with
the you know public transport situations
over the next six months i
don't see that going anywhere i think
businesses will have to adjust if they
don't
lose people you know those people go to
businesses that may be better equipped
and
more susceptible to having people work
from home
and giving them a bit more flexibility
and ultimately trust
uh so i think those working conditions
um will be would be really interesting
to
to see what evolves and then i think
then i think
then i think you know we we might see
some some
some growth uh in a in a handful of
sectors some some interesting sectors i
think we'll see spikes and
in growth in a couple of those so
software engineering as
an example ash it's been a pleasure
thank you pleasure mate thanks very much